with piece of the tensor 22 topological
order so basically the basic question is
given a local 10 * out of which will
build a tensor network state how as a
properties of the global state related
to the local tensor so what does a
low-fat tensor tell us about the global
state so that would be the general theme
of the talk and that's a question we've
been working on since a long time with
ignacio that viet is Frank and a number
of other people so so the aim of this
talk is that I would like to try i want
to try to convince you why we are very
excited about how certain properties of
the local tensor allow us to expend a
lot of different things about the global
state if there's time at the end i will
try to make a connection also two chiral
phases so that's very decent works it
works it has a poster of that actually
so i encourage you to go there where we
find that may be similar properties also
show up in chiral phases which seem to
be intimately related with the fact that
these models archival and well that's
one reason why we are very excited about
discovering these symmetries because in
the non-tidal case very similar
sympathies have allowed us to explain a
lot of different properties of the of
the system ok so feel free to interrupt
me I mean I have a couple of notes but
i'm happy to deviate from the notes so
last time when i talk to you in the
wednesday meeting i made it through the
first three lines of my notes but I mean
that certified from you it works ok um
ok so much in my talk I will consider
two dimensional tensile networks I will
join if you look at a square lattice so
I will typically note that answer just
by well a bubble with five legs right so
we have some auxiliary relax alpha beta
gamma delta and some physical lag right
so we have some tensor a vector gamma
delta and where we just use a standard
notation right whenever we connect lakhs
of tensor it means that we identify the
corresponding index and with some over
that index and well these tensile
networks we can put them on various
geometries so what I will consider is
either on a torus
or I will also consider state on the
cylinder so where I put this network
onto a cylinder now in the case of a
cylinder there are various possibilities
so I could put the state on the cylinder
and choose to terminate the open links
at the boundary in some way but
typically i rather consider the case in
which they're open links at the boundary
when i talk about a cylinder which
basically means what I did is I took a
tensile network which I put on a torus
where there are links kind of going all
around and I chopped it into two pieces
say so they're linked sticking out which
kind of tell me how I have to entangle
this cylinder with kind of the other
half of the tourists to just do the
whole tours together again mmm okay so
what I'm interested in this is mostly
models where I can write so basically
solver the model someone's where I can
just write down a tensor that's what
Enzo networks can be used for many
different things they can be used for
numerics they can be used to to build
solid models so we are more interested
here in the sort of model aspect which
basically means that we have an aunt
that slave and well the idea is indeed
that we kind of start from a tensor and
this tensor on the one hand allows us to
construct the wave function
so let's call this side but on the other
hand the same kind of nut age is the
same tensor also allows us in fact to
construct the Hamiltonian which has well
which is the sum of local terms and
which has this way thank to function as
its exact ground state so in that sense
one could think of this tensor is really
being like like a central object rather
than starting from a Hamiltonian and
then studying the ground state we can as
well start from a tensor and
simultaneously obtain a Hamiltonian and
the ground state which we can study and
so how is this Hamiltonian obtained just
to give a brief sketch so please feel
free to interrupt if you want more
details right I'm trying to be a bit
sketchy and kind of cover various topics
but if you feel you want to know more
details please let me know right so the
idea is that if we if we take such a
tense on network state and we we cut a
region out of that state others so if we
cut some region out of the state way we
look at the reduced state and say these
four sides what we see that the reduced
density operator well must be of the of
the following form right it must be
given by a small tents on network where
we have physical indices and we just put
an arbitrary boundary condition on these
legs here because we don't really know
what the environment will do if we just
look at the reduced density operator and
the thing is that what we see is that
well the degrees of freedom on which
this reduced operator live they scale
like the volume right so if the physical
dimension small V this will scale like D
to the l times l right which is the
volume if that's a block of length L
here like Alice to in this case and the
boundary degrees of freedom scale like
some capital D which is just a property
of the tensor i did a fixed fixed
numbers this case like d to the four
times n write the circumference so we
can see if we choose our block L
sufficiently large it will always happen
at some point that this number is larger
than that number which means that the
state does not occupy the reduced
density operator
occupy the full space so we can always
use this to write an operator small age
which is one minus the projector on to
the support of Rho which means that well
any state which is cut out of such a
tensile network will have energy 0
whereas there will be other states which
have energy higher than 0 at least there
should be some right because this
doesn't have full rank so this is not a
trivial operator and then we can build
this parent Hamiltonian up here and
indeed one relevant question is under
which conditions will such models say be
unique ground states or grounds it was a
control the generous e of the
corresponding parent Hamiltonian right
otherwise this framework would be pretty
useless if the semitone has a huge
ground space degeneracy which we cannot
control right under controlled behavior
of the ground space of the semitone Ian
ok so in this talk I would like to
highlight which properties this tensor
needs to have in order to obtain systems
this topological order with a ground
state degeneracy which depends on
whether the topology of the the many
follow which you put it so say where
it's not unique on the torus but it
depends kind of on some properties of
the model but for this maybe let me
first introduce what topological or that
states are for those who don't know
other questions concerning the general
counsel network language I was kind of
short I assume that given it's a tense
on net web conference also there some
non tensile network people here I guess
yeah
well I'm indeed well in sometimes that's
what I do right I just look at at a
small patch of tensors right i mean you
don't have to go via this state we are
big state and then look at the reduced
ad did that's what you're not doing I
mean if I would construct the global
said they would have to actually praised
and see what what the boundary condition
is I get by tracing but I don't do that
right I just assume any possible
boundary conditions and it could mean
that due to the structure of the state
there are certain boundary conditions
which cannot even no cure so indeed in
sometimes the semitone is not
constructed by taking the global state
and looking at reduced density operators
but by just looking at the form of this
tensor and asking for what reduced
density operator says it'll lower so in
some sense it's really a local
construction and then you can come up
with the examples where this doesn't it
make a difference I'm sorry what
well that's indeed an interesting I was
a difficult question and so indeed then
one aim of this talk is to give
conditions under which we know that the
relative journalist is controlled and it
will turn out this has a number of I
mean this condition has a number of
additional consequences like an ionic
excitations protection of edge physics
and so on so but indeed the original aim
where we did this was indeed to answer
exactly that question to figure out what
are the conditions such that we have a
topological generous see okay so any
more questions okay so
so what is topological order well the
basic idea of topological order is that
well I guess that different place to
define topological order so I just
choose one and I I will basically stick
to one example the Torah code which is
kind of the simplest example and use
this to illustrate the basic ideas but I
mean it's these things work for more
general examples it's just it's easier
to you know present it for a simple
example so we have to San Antonio and it
should have some degenerate ground space
which depends on the topology and it
might also have excitation which are the
interesting statistics which are an
ionic which means that you know if you
cannot create them individually you have
to play them in pairs if you move them
around each other you have interesting
phases or even non abbia behavior and
well then there are other ways to define
topological order starting from the
ground state for instance asking if I
take some state or just from a state
which well we say is a ground state so
given some state on some lattice we can
cut some region a out of the lattice and
ask for the entanglement properties of
that region a right and for instance we
can ask for the entanglement entropy of
this review state so the entropy of the
reduced out of a which quantifies the
entanglement and well typically we
expect for systems which which have some
translation symmetry in which are
grounded at the intendant's case like a
boundary so it will be proportional to
the boundary of that region but in
topological systems as a correction
which is which is kind of independent of
the shape of this region a it just well
once once you subtract the linear part
you will get something like that or that
the states can also have non-trivial
non-trivial transformation properties
see if Weaver pay its estate or tilt the
state or something like that it will
behave in a way which we don't expect
for for a simple stay tuned to exhibit
but okay so so there are various ways to
characterize these things always kind of
see all these phenomena later once we
once we have this characterization here
but let's just start from a simple
example so that's the Torah code state
so let's kind of the simplest of logic
model I guess one can write down and the
idea is that we look at a model which is
which lives on a square lattice and we
have we have spin switch sit on the
edges of the lattice so there's a spin
on every edge and now we want to look at
at a state well we now I will mark an
edge event if that spin isn't in state
one right it's a qubit so it can be 0 1
I will mark the ones and I want I want
to consider states where these ones form
loops where these ones from closed loops
black here and now I want to consider a
state which is of the form that it's a
uniform superposition over all possible
new patterns so I will occasion we omit
the lattice because the lattice is not
that important in the end but there
should be a uniform way to opposition of
really all possible loop patterns of
that form and well it turns out that one
can find a Hamiltonian for that I will
not give it explicitly but the idea that
the Hamiltonian have should have two
types of terms it should have one term
which which gives an energy penalty of
their non closed loops so if the number
of ones adjacent to a certain edge is
not even and it should have a second
term which is kind of a resonance term
which says that if I have a loop I can
change it for instance by flipping this
part of the loop here and deform it into
a different loop and this way I will
enforce at least loops appearance with
equal weight whenever they can be
deformed by such a move
and certainly if I put this on whatever
rectangular area if I don't care about
boundary conditions and you do pattern
can be different to any other loop
pattern that way right by doing local
updates now it turns out that this model
indeed has if I if I think about the
Hamiltonian of that form it has
different ground state sector if I put
it on a non-trivial geometry say on a
torus and how can I see that
well if you have this model on a torus
that's considered to possible kind of
initial state and then we try to ask if
I want this loop pattern to be contained
what should be the corresponding grounds
they've given the way the hamiltonian x
+ 1 could be a state where i have a loop
going around the torus and one could be
where have no loop going around the
torus now you see well this this Justin
forces loop constraint so this is the
interesting term because it kind of
tries to change your patterns but all
this can do is it can create new loop
patterns and indeed i can continue like
that right so I I can try to go around
the Toros I can come back here but you
see the last step will actually create
two loops not one so these kind of loops
this kind of moves will never be able to
create a single loop they can only get
pairs of loops so the penalty of loops
across this cut and equally the penalty
of loops along this cut here is an
invariant right it cannot be changed by
such a Hamiltonian so there are indeed
different ground state sectors and they
are characterized by the parity of loops
going around the tours in the two
directions so there are four different
ground states
and it's also kind of straightforward to
see that this model should indeed have
this topological correction to the
entropy because if you cut any region
you can ask how many of these strings of
these clothes lines will I cut and
because these four clotheslines a number
of lines I cut always has to be even so
there's basically a constraint as e to
type of constraint so in a logarithmic
way like in the entropy they should
exactly no correction of one or ln2 or
whatever okay any questions okay so so
how can I present this month as a
tensile network state mmm so for this
I'm going to rotate my letters by 45
degrees but the basic arguments I gave
on how to don't really depend how my
lettuce is oriented so i will look at a
rotated lettuce so we have this lettuce
here see if I get this done wisely and
well there's some kind of loop patterns
on this lettuce read something like this
and this loops go on and whatever and
now what I what I will do is I will
redraw this latest by decorating the
edges in such a way that that I will
insert horizontal or vertical lines and
then just redraw the same pattern so
basically here i insert horizontal lines
and your vertical lines and so on
let me see so if I try to really draw
the same figure but you see this works
out this should look roughly like this
there's nothing here
after this basic is the same figure as
before just that I inserted some
horizontal lines here and vertical lines
here and so on so I can try the same
kind of loop pattern on this lattice but
I still say there are only spins here
right this is just a way to graphically
depict the thing in a slightly different
way because what I can do now is that I
can I can I can cut some blocks out of
this lattice like this and this will be
my these with my dancers now right so I
take each of these use purple blocks and
say okay I build a tensor which well has
these legs here let's take this guy here
let's look at that one so I put these
legs here like this
and then what I have is something like
that ok so I have spin sitting here here
and here so these prints are in the one
state there's a force physical spin
sitting here which isn't a zero state so
that's that's a physical part of my
tensor and then if a subsidiary indices
going in all pass in or all four
directions and again whenever I have a
red line I put a 1 here and otherwise I
put a zero the picture clear so it's
kind of just the way to cut a piece of
these strings and say whenever a string
is going into one of these elementary
plackets I put a 1 and where there's no
string I put a 0 and the thing is every
string pattern and in the inside has a
unique way at the outside right because
the strings must be closed now there are
two observation so if i define might
answer as follows what has to hold it
because these guys from closed loops is
that whenever a loop is entering it also
has to leave right which means that I
have a parity constraint on the sky
on the boundary right so if i try to all
the tensor in the way I usually draw
tensors like this so these are the four
boundaries and this is this is this big
physical system here then what I have is
that I can take this tensor and I know
that it has to live in the even parity
subspace which means that I can act with
some symmetry operation on it which in
this case it's just a policy evil and it
will stay invariant because it's in the
even parity subspace and well the second
important thing is that within this even
parity subspace so this symmetry is like
one condition and this will be kind of
the basic condition i will look at but
typically what is important is that the
symmetry kind of fully specify the
support of the tensor which means that
whenever i am either in the even parity
subspace by looking at the physical
configuration i can infer this
configuration so there's no additional
ambiguity when quit live is a little
ambiguity but it can cause trouble it
can cause additional generous ease so we
generally want to consider the case
where this the symmetry fully specifies
the support of this tensor on the
auxiliary degrees of freedom
fully specify
ok so this property is what we what we
term g injective so injective because if
there wouldn't be a symmetry the
condition would be that this tensor
doesn't have any symmetries it would
mean that if I look at the map from the
auxiliary decrease to the physical
systems a map is injective it maps
different boundary conditions it doesn't
have a kernel direct that was injected
means g injective because there's a
symmetry group so in that case i would
probably call it Z to injective so
actually in one of these days Utah will
talk about a generalization of this
concept were much larger class of models
but I would really focus on this one and
well it turns out that the symmetry
together with since injectivity
condition allows us to prove a lot of
different conditions on topological
order and the type of order in the
system no no I'm not doing a
transformation of the physical space
that's that that's not important it's
kind of a hidden symmetry you could find
the gauge symmetry also a powerful was
funny to gauge symmetry but it's kind of
a hidden symmetry in the representation
so it basically tells you that this
tensor is only ready I think we'll see
later it relates a lot of things you can
already see in this small picture it
kind of relates this topological
connection because as I said this
connection comes from the fact that
whenever I call it a cutter region the
number of strings crossing the
boundaries even and this condition is of
course a kind of smallest elementary
version of exactly that statement that's
a number of strings crossing the
boundaries even but there's no physical
symmetry associated to it this will be
very different when it was a physical
symmetry actually translate to such a
symmetry action would mean that the
state has actually a symmetry in the
sense of you know why I transformed the
state under unitary cancer and it's
invariant physical
sorry some creases you make physical and
sensory I mean this case it's just that
that's that's not what I'm interested in
and it's a discrete symmetry right and
with a continuous symmetry this would
basically just just probably completely
kill the whole cancer and especially you
couldn't have a lot of nice property so
we really focus on finite symmetry
groups so I will really just use the
tool but you could indeed use any
symmetry group as long as your
representation has some reasonable
properties like having bali lips okay so
so I mean I mean luckily do proofs I
will try to illustrate why the symmetry
gives rise to all these topological
features if you if you want to have
proof that we know but probably I will
not give the whole truth anyway so there
is a little more like the toilet try to
illustrate why these things are
important so I should also say that very
recently we have discovered a very
similar flavor symmetry with very
similar properties in in discarded
fermionic states which is therefore well
we already found they give rise to some
some very related properties and we hope
that they give authorized to some other
properties which we expect to be there
so so what is important about the
symmetry well a very elementary property
which is important that it concatenates
nicely Oh detonation
so if i take two tensors and concatenate
them rabbit i have to do if i call a
tensor network you can very easily see
that because each of the ten source is
invariant under an action of Z I could
see everywhere and Z on the second
cancer disease here cancel out so what I
find is that the joint penser is also
invariant and I mean obviously this case
this keeps going on like that if I grow
and grow my system in fact it turns out
that the whole injectivity property
mainly that there is no additional
current and the whole thing also carries
over but that's kind of important ideas
is similarly stable that's that's a very
important defining property of such a
symmetry you want something which you
can concatenate and you have the same
property on larger scales because
otherwise it's not very useful to have
something a local scale which doesn't
carry over to the global system mmm okay
so what does this imply so let's imagine
we take let me write the caption also i
give it a waiver okay so so let's
imagine which we take a big tensile
network and i will just void from the
top i will not really draw the physical
industries because they're not so
important so we just take a piece of a
tensor network
so they're physically this is sticking
out right in our direction and this
thing is on the torso know whatever it
doesn't matter i just look at a small
patch and the question is if i have a
bunch of these strings sitting on one of
forming a string forming a chain on one
of these links what can i say about them
so we have some string here now this
thing is only an imagined string what
you two will explain there will be
actual strings which have actual tensor
indices themselves but the idea is tend
to think of this as a string it's like a
line of these a string of these well we
know that this tensor has a symmetry
here right so it means that in
particular if we have onesies sitting
here at the tensor so now again this is
a top view if you have to stop view i
have here it means that i can take
onesie and because the whole thing is
invariant in the putting z everywhere i
put it everywhere it Kansas up here so
in fact it is a different way to write
this equation is to say that i can move
zzz through these sensors all right so i
can start doing this anywhere i want i
can take this Z and instead put it here
so what happens that I deformed this
string and now it's the same argument I
can of course take 2 z's and move it to
the other side that so I can take these
two Z's and put them here
and I can keep on doing so all right
that's kind of a bit tedious on the
blackboard but you can see I can keep
doing that I can keep I can keep
deforming the string at we'll all right
I can move it wherever I want so they
move up the strings in these systems
which I can place but which which don't
have a well-defined location there there
I can't make them go away but I can push
them wherever I want mmm so why is this
exciting well one reason why the strings
are exciting is because we can use them
to parameterize the ground space
so how do we do that well we we can put
the thing on a torus so let's say this
is a whole Taurus right so i imagine
periodic boundaries and now what i can
do is i can put one of the string of Z's
onto this guy here i would just watch
string now in a pet but it means that at
every intersection there's actually a Z
sitting on the tensor index now if I put
a string like that what happens why the
string put be moved anywhere in the
system but it wraps around the tourists
in this picture right so effectively
what I do is a string going around the
tourists right so what I know is that
following this argument here I can take
the string and move it wherever I want
but I cannot get rid of it right so it
will affect the state in some way or the
other on the other hand if you remember
how we define parent are components for
these models what we did was that we
said okay we take a small block find
that block and we put arbitrary boundary
conditions right and we look at the
reduced density operator of the state in
that block now obviously all this
ensures is that the state can be locally
working by just putting a few tensors
together with some boundary condition
now this still holds here right because
the string could be anywhere I can't
assign it a location so the Hamiltonian
here has in fact no chance of seeing a
string because I could have put this
thing anywhere right it's just describes
the same state because it's a symmetry
so indeed I can do this in while
horizontal or vertical direction so this
way I can parameterize a ground state
manifold
which is nice for from for many reasons
well we this way we can enumerate the
grounds that we can categorize them we
can also find a full parameterization of
all possible ground States so for
instance one can use this to construct
things like minimally entangled states
which are which are useful to determine
topological properties of the system so
these are states which have a a
different entanglement across a
topological non-trivial cut and pier one
can really get the full perimeter
ization in terms of Pepsi one can gather
a pencil network for the whole manifold
yes no and that's actually hard work ok
I think that's what's hard work no it's
not indeed the thing is the following if
it would take more complicated groups
prepares for where all these
correlations that's a fair point yes
this this would not have this
injectivity property right presumably
well this would have more symmetry if
it's completely detached there must be
something else going on right if I mean
if you have a virtual layer which never
Maps the physical system if it must have
a stronger symmetry than just this one
because it must be completely it must be
completely factorize threat
exactly we make a physical product state
in the functional thing is also product
state like Z eigenstates but if then you
have this property right if these are
all 0 states then the virtual system is
in the 0 state read it's invariant and
the Sigma Z but it's also abandoned the
more things maybe just a single Sigma Z
so it doesn't have this what I cause
injectivity property but it is hard work
and even if you have this injectivity
property it's not that every difference
thing will give you a different ground
state in that Tommy cold case yes you
can prove it let's put this probably but
sorry well not also gonna depend in the
first place right i mean it depends on
the structure of this tensor like how
close it is to an isometry or not if
it's actually a struggle but i think the
basic question is linear independence
but i mean anyway you would get an over
parameterization of utah state manifold
which might still be fine you might just
felt care and i mean there are cases
where this is actually very nice that
you can / parameterize and play with
some extra parameters otherwise it
depends on the group if the group is a
billion you get exact exactly well each
string gives you a different different
ground state if it's not a billion you
get less and this relates to the fact
that there is a certain way to count the
ground states using reps of normalizer
not a billion [ __ ] poopless so much to
your bro memorizing a big one
well within equals element of the group
right so so this thing is labeled why
with any each at each link what i have
is i have a representation ug sipping
say the aggregate representation for
simplicity and here i also have a
representation setting of a different
group age so in principle the granting
is parametrized by g & age now if this
group is not a billion there are some
important points i said these things can
be moved right and that's why they all
give ground states now the thing is that
if if these groups are non abelian it
can happen that the crossing of these
strings is tied ok so it's actually not
sufficient to say that the strings can
be moved I mean singles things can be
moved but you also want the two strings
can be moved so it means that you can
move once one thing through the other so
what you can kind of see is if you do
exactly the same argument but you have
two strings so you would have a second
string so you have let's see so you have
this group element G sitting here right
and H sitting here or horizontally now
if you try to move this down what you do
is you put H here H here and so on right
so you see this thing is going like this
now and this thing of G is going like
that but you see if G and H there should
be an inverse somewhere I don't being a
bit sloppy especially numerous because
they should cancel you see that H has
two computers G for instance otherwise
you will not be able to pull this thing
down so you get some conditions right
one conditions that G has to commute
with age and the second condition is
that basically because you know that you
can just meet it you can just take a
single tensor and add a new symmetry
element K everywhere because that's an
invariant and then you can start blowing
this invariant and it will kind of code
these strings right if we keep growing
at some point it gets stuck at the
string so which means that you can just
put this K around all things everywhere
which means that when you have something
limit by GH this is equivalent to
putting another element K around eight
turns out that if you count this
equivalence classes you get exactly what
you expect for quantum doubles of the
corresponding group also the counting
there is done in a slightly different
way using conjugacy classes and it rips
off normal I zehrs sorry well that's
again hard work I don't think I can I
can explain any more than that without
preparing even with preparing it would
probably take too long actually but you
can have to discuss it later maybe you
two will give more details in a more
general framework okay so you two will
have to give more details okay what we
were commenting this big you know the
hope the setup is is really the same as
what you have in or before to form a
building be seated discovery of the
structure of quantum dots
things exactly the same is this body
just exactly so it's basically there's a
just engaged in their sunday clothes in
education and so what about the
minimally things fits you well and then
one design a lecture about that it was
just kind of an American said I think if
they will talk about things like that
but i know that this abstract you know
he's doing but I just to get jobs right
do I have the first day early as
possible i talked about it no related it
is totally how much of that carries over
to the gaussian perhaps case may be
discrete symmetry on that when the kind
of car is that you're clever pitocin
tips and they consider for this kyle
perhaps indeed i mean that's one reason
why who i want to talk about this my
we're very excited again about these
things is that in the kind of case we
find some kind of related similar
symmetry it's not really a product of
operators it's kind of more like a zero
momentum to make how are we doing in
time i have like 15 minutes sir because
it's all for that data there you know
but i mean like i mentioned it briefly
just to kind of make make the link
because otherwise i will be over and i
haven't made the link and I think it'd
be nice to make a link so in the
fermionic case what we see is that
we can build a pep study similarly so
the way we think about it now is that we
say we prepare some initial 5 / tight
stated a physical and virtual system
sorry one and then we apply projections
or to some kind of accommodated states
this is had a bit easier because it
allows to work with my animals but the
point is that they exist some operator
acting on this boundary on a single side
which eliminates a state in this
operator when something is slightly
different like in the simplest case
something sea levels are my own and
operate put me something like that and
what we find is that again by projecting
onto a pure state of tomorrow and I
operators say here this this symmetry is
kind of carried over and grown and we
get a bigger symmetry of the same kind
so indeed in the end what we get is we
got kind of strings looping around any
region so very similar to what i said
here and again these strengths can be
basically the statue that one can build
strength of that type on the on the peps
and pull it through the system so these
would again allow to say parameterize
different ground states and indeed the
model we have is also gapless of the are
two ground States and one thing one can
do is for instance indeed parameter has
two different ground state that way
huh so this so this gives a proof that
it's got sorry does that indeed this the
little thing that is countless but this
is a way to to construct sting
indeed this is a way to construct a
second the grounds database well well it
is no depends on when you just you just
said the gap how do you know the guns
well we know what peritoneum the first
pocket on the phone it is and that we
know that they have had your blankie
became correlation suppose you have like
we have this one parameter family at one
and there's some other models I can even
know that the corresponding local
Hamiltonian is schedulers and that
indeed you know having the sympathy will
tell you that probably even if you
switch on interactions and you try to
keep the symmetry which might be a good
way to try to make an exact amount out
of that it would slowly still be
degenerate but my thought it might see
me get right on it I guess we're
impacting water that's very well
considerable that you have two ground
States but then the gap above them but
we don't know that's but you know given
that this symmetry is kind of very
closely type as with topological order
for conventional phases in tensile
networks it feels that this is a very
interesting observation which might tell
us how how one could could extend this
construction beyond the Gaussian case
you think that the symmetry is indeed
very closely related to the fact that
they are indeed Qaeda ledge notes so i
have to think how i go on but i can also
say something about that or i can stick
to another spin system so we can talk
about it later maybe or at our supposta
to discuss this on your poster yes okay
so there are a lot of more things which
which come out of these strings why
should I continue
okay so what else can we do with these
strings but another thing we can with
these drinks instead of just
parameterizing ground States you can
also put such a string on the lattice so
say a string of Z's and then we just
stop the string okay so this thing kind
of stops at the plaque kept here the
black hat is indeed special right
because we can move this string again
using the symmetry to leave the plaque
in this direction but it will always end
at the plug head so that's the only one
which has an odd number of Z's attached
to it and well it turns out that this is
indeed just forms an excitation of the
system right because the fact that
there's an endpoint of the string that's
something you can observe by putting a
hamiltonian because you can't just move
the string away the augment was we can
move things away but we can't move the
end Part C and ones are fixed right
because this is odd number of these at
this blockade that's a parity constraint
we cannot change that so it turns out
this where you can also model
excitations and for instance you see
these exit actors have to come in pairs
right because you put you put a string
it has it has two end points so indeed
these excitations come in pairs so it
wouldn't it be interesting in this
chiral models to see what happens if I'm
put such a string in the mother has an
end point whereas it gives any kind of
excitations well it should but
especially what what properties is
excitations have if they have any any
other character and they're just normal
from yannick excitations let's recall
the elementary excitations magnetic say
the electric ones of it will click in
this picture
I'm asking whether that the usual
polarize different article yeah I think
I've had a noise and I most constructed
this trip sorry they were even first
construction this well kind of thing you
put a string well with all pets but I
guess otherwise you may not know exactly
what I'm probably not okay that's before
my time I guess okay they're actually a
lot of other things one can understand
display for instance of a normalization
transformations i'm not sure if you two
will talk about these things and more
general context that one can basic in a
scent of a normalization as an effect
that there is a unit area which will met
pencil product of this representation to
a scene with a presentation to see terms
or identity or something like that let's
that these representations are actually
as a morphic that relates effect can
renormalize these models so that well a
block of two sides which has a symmetry
of z pens for z is no different in a
single block plus something trivial yeah
recovering from the various vision that
they are very present in an hour so it
is all based on the power we have to
not really no I mean excitation to
always be x occasions but if you go away
from the fixed point wave functions
there maybe not the elementary
excitations but they were former basis
of low-lying states right it's it's not
completely evident that this will be
exactly the excitation if you go away
from the Torah code point and the thing
is that indeed at some point you might
even cause a phase transition so maybe I
can spend 10 minutes on that because I
think that's actually quite interesting
what happens if you take these tensors
which have this symmetry but then you go
very far away from a point where they're
close to an isometry and it turns out
that they're actually phase transitions
can appear to the so description in some
sense breaks down and very funny things
happen in some way when I decide what
I'm going to do become more loads or
less but maybe we'll talk about that
because I think it fits very nicely and
if I might be able to given an idea
within 10 minutes hmm so-so indeed one
one of the questions is the following
indeed like back if I asked how much
does it depend on the fact that we're at
their Torah code point in some sense it
doesn't I mean a number of ground state
and the fact that these describe
excitations doesn't depend on that but
the question is what does it mean and
well what happens if you if you go to
the thermodynamic limit for instance and
so let's let's see if we can modify the
tensor in a way which keeps the symmetry
but changes its properties and for this
okay so the point this one can take the
topic code and add what people call
string tension so we had that the Torah
code is a superposition of all possible
configurations of loops right now we can
add string tension or fugacities or
whatever one might call it and define a
state's i lambda where loops are
suppressed right so that that in flag
tension right this looks like one to be
shorter and they are suppressed by the
total length of the loop the total
length of all loops right so basically
each each loop segment gives a factor of
lambda it's suppressed by a factor of
lambda and the point that this can be
very easily done on the level of the
elementary
tensors because what we had originally
was at the elementary tensor was just a
way to represent a loop on a single
square right the tensor kind of looked
like this so we can very easily put some
lambda here which has exactly this
effect right that lambda suppresses
having a string so lambda would be
something like a diagonal matrix 1
lambda tensor for acting on all four
sides mmm and well it's actually well
known that this model has a phase
transition so one could ask what happens
is more likely at the base transition
going to a trivial phase which seems to
be a bit contradictory with the fact
that we have four different ground
states so one might wonder what actually
happens at this phase transition and
okay I think that they're not sure but
it next to the Ising model if that's
what you want to know I wouldn't get it
was that 0.64 something yes but anyway
it's it's the Ising model right I mean I
mean this is not the Ising model but you
can map it i mean you come up its
transfer operator essentially to the
Ising model transfer operator so you
know what the critical point should be
so actually Casanova and someone I think
we're the first to actually study this
phase transition and show that for
instance a topological entropy has a
jump exactly at this critical point okay
so how much time do I have ten minutes
five where's my chairman oh that's my
chair like 10 minutes okay
that was a plan okay they have other
wishes fine tunings okay I'm happy to
talk about whatever I am and we asked as
soon as long as I can answer it okay so
what happened at the phase transition so
to understand what happened at the phase
transition we have to look what is what
is known as a transfer operator do I
already used it but it didn't call it
the transfer rate how did you call it
double tensor so anyway so so let me try
to first draw it in one dimension so if
you have a one-dimensional tense on that
recommends product state and we ask for
instance what is the overlap of two
different states or how do correlation
functions behave what we have to compute
is we have to take a cat stay the brass
state could be a different state in
principle described by a different
answer B if we look at say overlaps and
then we might put some operator a X here
and why here if you want to know a
correlation function and we contract all
the legs in between right so we see that
it's a distance is big basically the
important object will be this thing here
which which mediates a coupling between
the left and the right edge and you can
see that kind of the spectral behavior
of this guy will be important because if
you take a higher power the leading
eigen value will remain and the other
ones will be suppressed and give a
length scale which relates to the ratio
of the eigen values but it's not
actually not what I want to focus i
would really want to focus mostly on
overlaps of states so we have this tends
to operate at T which could be the
correspond to well let's limit by a and
B which are the tensors a and B
corresponding to the two states and if
we take this on a chain with periodic
boundaries which is long what will we
have we will have that the overlap of
these two states is equal to the trace
of tab2 the mpower if any of the length
of the chain
so this will be roughly gamma a B to the
power n where gamma a B is a largest
eigen value of this operator T right by
it census doesn't make much sense that
of course what I should do is I should
take the normalized overlap right so in
principle what I want to look at is
something like this so you see that this
will be something like gamma a B divided
by gamma a gamma be B to the N so what
is important if this number is 1 or
smaller than 1 this will tell me if
these states are equal orthogonal in the
one-dimensional case so now what we want
to look at is a two-dimensional case so
what happens in the two-dimensional case
when the two-dimensional case of a
chance of operator is a bit more
complicated so we're looking at a
cylinder ok so this state sits on a
cylinder so this guy has periodic
boundary conditions and this is a
corresponding two-dimensional transfer
operator so again if we want to know how
different states say different ground
states which we just wrote down relate
to each other we have to look at this
object but things are potentially more
tricky now I mean this quantity is
either one or it's smaller than one and
then we take a limit of n to infinity
and it goes away or it doesn't now this
thing here again depends on the other
dimension right so we have two ends we
have envied which is this dimension here
and we have a length and age so this
power here is an age but these guys here
depend all on envy so it could be that
this thing is not one but slightly
smaller than one but it goes to one
quickly enough to compensate for the
exponential suppression so one has to
look more closely in uniform ones to
make an assessment about overlaps of
states of a relation of states to each
other in two dimensions mmm
okay so how does it have a pack of
logical order so so the important thing
is that well again we have the slope is
symmetry that well each tensor is in
bank under the action of Z now this
extends to the whole column right
because it's stable so we know that the
whole column has this invariance
property it's invent interacting with a
symmetry action everywhere and the same
is true in the bra layer not only in the
cat-lair so what we have is we have this
operate a tea here and we find that well
p commutes if we I mean this is equal
just to the original thing right so we
can move this row of these here and then
we get a commutation relation so we have
that he commutes with a symmetry
operation even both on the cat and on
the bra independently so what does it
mean it means that well p has four
different blocks labeled by the
irreducible representations of this
action of z right so we know that p is a
direct sum of p alpha alpha prime where
I'll find alpha prime or plus or minus
one so the irreducible representations
of this action of Z and now but and in
fact to be precise er there's a second
type of plant operator may be the one
where i put this horizontal string here
right i could have put this horizontal
string and then put this thing on a
torus which means that then i might also
have some strings e here and or
something z here which well i can label
by phi and phi prime so the stance of
operator has again two more blocks
labeled by five and five prime and let
these actually correspond to exactly the
four different ground states whether I
have even or odd parity and whether I
put a string on a photo sphere
and so so the claim that the important
thing is how these that's on a synergy
but it's a possible ground state so I
want to talk about the overlaps of the
possible mm-hmm I mean the aim is to
capture to study basically the tenth
operator of the whole ground state
manifold well but I can handle the
bigger transfer matrix which is which is
characterized by I will be principal
them the way I think one one might think
of this one should be program if like
that we are going great you add just one
extra index of the inertial and this X
imagenext translation invariance of your
system in some sense but it doesn't make
it at the physical state just on the
virtual representation but that's not
surprising and it's there's a
topological sector which has I mean this
difficult all possible States Naga red I
mean other words of it's a bit that talk
to say that this thing is different but
projecting the connecticut sector is not
different in principle they are both on
pretty much equal footing right they
both correspond to some type of
excitation your system just that this
episode patient is much nicer with
respect to one of these these
expectations are the principal shimata
you can think of it like that right then
this is just an extra layer
and so it turns out exactly the behavior
of this tent fabric is what tells you
what happens at the phase transition so
if you look for it at this story for
this thing tension what you find is that
here is lambda 1 so that's topological
here is lambda 0 that's trivial and well
because we know that the transport by
that maps to the Ising model we can
actually we actually know what happens
but they can otherwise we can do
pneumatics for instance and what happens
is that something like that happens for
the different so this is the largest
eigen value of each parts of the sector
alpha phi alpha prime 51 so the
topological is in finishing it's very
simple what happens is the following
that these guys are one up to
exponentially small corrections in an
age right for a finite and agents what
has this typical [ __ ] a surrounding
these guys up here are the ones where
the cat in the garage index are equal
which we'd whoops which means that the
norm of all the foreground fit is equal
and these are all the guys which are off
diagonal right so where we're at least
alpha prime is not equal to five product
or alpha or files not equal to Phi prime
so this says that the overlap of these
different states in vanish in the
thermodynamic limit so these states are
actually orthogonal they describe
different from states if your system is
big in that this will depend on some
kind of length scale by Jewish group
pretty lady some correlation length in
your system let the first additional
situation changes drastically so what
happens is that now the situation is
more mixed actually so I would have to
think how to get a lay beside what what
happens physically as a following so up
here you have four different gamez again
so you have four guys here and four guys
here it's maybe not so surprising
because the eyes are on the side you all
right but they're different they're
labeled by different but by different
ground state is and what you will have
two ground States that's that simplifies
and just call this team you knew prior
when you goes from zero to three
the four different states now on we'll
have that say that this up here is gamma
0 0 gamma 0 1 and gamma 1 1 and gamma 1
0 so the two ground States where the
overlap matrix element is basically
equal to the norm right so they become
identical in the Sun organic limit which
is very surprising I mean that's that's
a very any treated behavior usually if
you have states we make them bigger than
become more thermal here what you have
is our state which are linearly
independent any finite volume but they
become more and more close as you make
your system bigger so in effect there's
only one stay there not to States and
down here is all the rest so what
happens is over less these states so in
particular there's a guy come between 2
and gamma 3 3 so these states have an
exponentially small norm which mean that
whenever you put the smallest
perturbation on them they will get
overlap with that guy might still be
exponentially small but because it's
guys so much the press they will
immediately open transform into that
state so they not stay by the
perturbations you can write them down by
the not stable so it turns out that you
need NFS salvation despite having the
symmetry suddenly you have a fascination
for Emil phase where actually is four
different states only describe one
actual state which one could say is
problematic but one can also say it's
very nice look at it actually allows us
to model topological phase transitions
within perhaps by choosing a large
enough symmetry saying which can
accommodate different possible
topological phases and then kind of
trying to shift shift the weight within
this live in the subspaces invariant
subspace such as we can get different
different possible behaviors ok I think
of there no questions
stop sir